I'd like to introduce our first speaker
and you knows
medical PhD engineer engineer here at
Yale he previously studied at university
of pennsylvania and boston university
where he honed his research interests
and knowledge of American pop culture
but his heart lies in his native country
of Mexico Mexico he can almost always be
found researching the immune system at a
lab but the rest of the time he is
likely playing soccer we're spending too
much time thinking about and obsessing
and tinkering with home audio equipment
and with that please welcome undress
go for it just to give you a brief what
it is like this is something that I was
completely passionate about and I came
up to my advice and said I want to do
this and they said yeah sure so I have a
question and the needle microphone and I
what looking for an answer so this is
exactly what being a scientist in
graduate school is like you have a
question and you literally just go and
see for the answer yourself so it's very
very exciting I'm going to talk to you
about is cancer immunotherapy and cancer
immunotherapy is the newest approach and
the most up-and-coming approach to treat
cancer is hopefully the one with the
most hopes for the future so what is
cancer immunotherapy it is retraining
your immune system so everything that's
already inside your own body to fight
cancer so you basically have all the
system of defenses to fight bacterial
infections bias infections and you can
retrain it to actually fight cancer so
to understand cancer immunotherapy we
need to look at two things the immune
system and cancer it's a battle between
these two forces and you have to kind of
see which part has the attacking and the
defense to kind of understand what is
going to be important in this battle so
let's talk about cancer first cancer is
probably defined as the disease of our
era we have spent so much money trying
to cure cancer and we have failed
miserably four point nine billion
dollars in research of year of the
government funds are spent every year
semi 7.4 billion and medical costs every
year and it is still the second leading
cause of death in the US one in every
four deaths in america is caused by
cancer that is ridiculous we've lost the
war on cancer an estimated 1.6 million
new diagnosis for people that are going
to have cancer only in 2013 and out of
those 580,000 half a million people are
going to die this year of cancer a
thousand six hundred every minute not
second but a minute that's pretty
drastic that's a pretty horrible
decision we're all trying to get a
solution for this so this is why this is
obviously a very important problem and
we need a new approach what we've done
so far it's not working now let's try to
understand what is cancer cancer itself
is not one this is actually a group of
many diseases and it's all characterized
by one single thing it's uncontrollable
growth of your own cells you have cells
all over your body and when they decide
to
crazy they still keep growing and
growing and dividing dividing and you
get a tumor and that tumor can be fatal
because if you have too much of that
mass it's going to get in the way of
other important parts of your body and
then you die so it is important to
understand that this abnormal growth is
due to abnormal genetic programming
every cell has a genetic program and
they follow a certain set of
instructions if this goes wrong then
they follow the wrong kind of
instruction that just keep growing
because after only gold and so because
of that these cells cancer cells can
express abnormal signals so the body can
actually recognize these abnormal
signals and tag them as something that's
not supposed to be there and that's
going to be the job of the immune system
so it's very important to remember that
these abnormal signals are part of the
cancer repertoire so going back to this
idea of the immune system versus cancer
we have to look at what the immune
system can do to fight cancer and how
we're going to reactivate it so immune
system is actually a multi-layered
defense system that's two layers of
Defense the first one is called the
innate immunity and the second one is
called adaptive immunity innate immunity
is the general defense that you have its
immediate and right away when you get
sick your body deploys this this attack
and its immediate you don't even feel it
it's it's dumb it's characterized by the
use of phagocytes and very big cells
they just are able to recognize
something that's not supposed to be
there and they eat it right away another
for example good example is every single
cell in your body if they detected
they're being attacked by a virus they
immediately shut down and they actually
commit suicide something called
apoptosis so that the virus cannot
spread yeah it's actually it's funny but
it's the best way to control virus
infection because if the cell is still
alive the virus will continue to
replicate and then that's bad for the
body so they kill themselves the virus
just as oh and then it gets eaten up so
we're gonna look at a specific example
which are called phagocytes these are
big sales that eat up all the bacteria
and everything that's not supposed to be
in your body and they're important
because they provide the link to the
adaptive immunity which is the most
important part we're going to talk about
but here is a quick video showing this
is called a neutrophil which is a type
of phagocyte and that black thing is a
bacteria so this is actually chasing
this bacteria right here and it's going
to eventually eat it and what they do is
they just chase it through
sorry about that they chase it and they
keep trying to get it until it finally
eventually eats it surrounds it and eats
it and that process actually very
important for the next part which is
adaptive immunity adaptive immunity is
what vaccines are all about for example
is the long lasting memory creating part
of your immune system and it's very very
specific so every single bacteria has a
specific little cell that can recognize
it and replicate and kill that specific
bacteria virus or in this case cancer so
why is it important there are three
major players in this adaptive immunity
details which are the effectors and the
regulars of the entire process B cells
would trade your antibodies which
potentiate the response which becomes
much stronger and APCs which are called
antigen presenting cells so that big
cell that was eating the bacteria that's
an antigen presenting cell so what it
does is it eats it chops it up into all
these pieces and all these proteins and
then displace the little segments kind
of a brutal it grabs a little piece and
just displace it in the surface t cells
recognize that only one specific T so
that is made to recognize that such as
oh that's what it's there replicates
like crazy and becomes helper cells or
killer cells killer cells are able to
kill the bacteria or the infection right
away helper cells are able to activate
other cells in the body that do the same
thing for example B cells so T cells
activate the B cells which create
antibodies and then this entire process
goes on but this takes about let's say
four or five days that's why when you
when you get sick or and you don't
actually feel being sick you don't feel
the fever four or five days later
because this is what's happening your
cells are replicating and then this
happens so what we're actually going to
focus on to fight cancer are T cells and
the reason this happens because these
are the effectors and the regulars these
are the actually the main part of your
immune system that we are all looking
for and actually we didn't know what
these o's did 30 years ago this is a
relatively new piece of science 30 years
ago you're like oh tea soda they're just
some cells there but now we know they're
the most important part of your immune
system so looking at that we have an
idea of how the immune system works
right the cell presents the buyers or
the bacteria and then the T cells
replicate and they regulate everything
and that's how it happens so how does
the musician actually recognize cancer
in exactly the same way but just instead
of dealing with a virus or a bacteria
and actually dealing with a tumor cell
so it grabs a tumor cell and it
recognizes a two more protein there is
such a thing because tumor cells are so
weird they're proteins are actually
mutated they don't have normal
protein so the cell can actually
recognize hey that's not normal and it
eats it up and presents it to the T so
that people becomes activated activates
the b-cells antibodies come out and that
is the way your immune system can
actually fight Katherine this happens
normally every single day you can
actually have this happening to you you
would never know because then you
wouldn't develop cancer but then how
does cancer get away if this is working
so perfectly how come everyone still has
cancer and the reason this happens is
because the actual immune system is much
more complicated and I just explained it
actually is a very sophisticated method
of regulation this is hard to see but
the green arrows and the red arrows are
two opposing forces the green hours mean
positive signals or the tea show is
going to get activated whereas the red
arrows mean negative signals which tell
the T so don't get activated relax and
don't do anything and this is important
because if your teachers were always
activated it would be attacking your own
body and then you would die so that's
not very good so this is very important
to have a regulation system of your
entire immune system so as you can tell
there's a lot of little signals and this
is just a small snippet there's many
hundreds of signals they say yes or no
to the T so they have to be constantly
checking for these signals and cancer is
so crazy smart that it up regulates the
negative signals so cancer has more of
these negative in this oncogenic pathol
which is a cancer pathway they just
express a lot of negative little
receptors in their cells and so T so
comes along and it receives a positive
signal telling it hey this is kind of
not a normal cell but at the same time
it also receives a negative signal and
most of the time the negative signal is
much stronger so cancer so the pieces
just ignore it and cancer is able to
grow so how do we deal with this problem
that the obvious answer to this is we
have to get rid of this negative signal
right if we want the T source recognize
it just get rid of the negative signal
and make the tea seller targets so I'm
actually going to show you some very
very very cool idea and is actually been
approved by the FDA so this was a
process that last a very long time but
it's recently been approved by the FDA
so it's actually being used in patients
right now and it is exactly that
canceling the negative signal one of
these receptors that creates a negative
signals called ctla-4 ctla-4 is
expressed on these T cells and it is
able to receive a negative signal so if
we create an antibody which binds to
this receptor and blocks it from
receiving a negative signal which is
exactly done right here you will only
get positive signal and the teasel
becomes hyperactivated and is able to
kill cancer and is actually shown
very promising response and patience so
this is this is actual data from from
the phase 3 trials which is the most
important trial when you're trying out
new drug you see this white spot right
here this is a lung cancer so you see
this white spot that's a big tumor after
treatment completely gone see all these
little spots right here kind of hard to
see but they're there those are all
metastatic tumor so it's very like a
dance form of cancer all there after
treatment completely gone completely on
and again here's a brain tumor so in
another tissue that spot is another
tumor completely gone all these all
these are figures right here show the
side effects of having an outer immune
therapy which activates on your immune
system so sometimes your white cells are
going to start attacking your own body
but this can all be very easily
controlled taking treatments have been
using for many many years so this is not
really a big issue in using this drug so
this is actually very exciting no that's
better okay but what's even more
promising which is why cancer
immunotherapy is the most exciting thing
we have to treat cancer right now is
this so when you deal with uncle uncle
therapies you're going to try and see
how can we increase the survival of the
mean population taking this medicine so
fifty percent survival so when fifty
percent are still alive they have to
survive longer so this is what normal
treatment we have right now they survive
about eight months and if we use this
this other immunotherapy treatment they
survive an extra six months and that's
really doesn't mean that's for four
people encounter that's like well it's
amazing but it's pretty mediocre let's
do this from the reality like this six
months are still going to die but was
very exciting that this is only shown by
immunotherapy because it's true look at
that but what's very excited about
immuno but very exciting about
immunotherapy is that we have this
elevated baseline right here that we
don't have with any other cancer
treatment so about eighteen to twenty
percent of the patients actually go on
and live four five six ten years on
without any recurrence without any
problems in the future and that is
something that's unique to this
treatment and the reason that's unique
is because immune of immune therapy
creates memory so your your actual body
is able to remember what cancer looks
like and that's memory cells in there
and it says you're never going to be all
have cancer again because it creates a
memory for cancer so you're basically
immune to cancer and that is something
that's unique to being able to use your
own body to fight it so this is exactly
what we're now focusing on racing this
baseline up and up and up until 80 90
100 percent of the patients can survive
ever because their body knows how to
fight it we don't have to intervene
anymore so that's the exciting that's
the entire point of this kind of
treatment so the future yes squares yes
and not so the different kinds of cancer
depends on tissue type but the different
the idea of cancer is presenting
oncogenic proteins so it's not like for
example when people get different types
of cancer it all started one place and
then it spread everywhere the thing is
cancer is able to mutate to it and of
tissue and it's just it's a little bit
more complicated or not but yes you have
a point but the idea would be that your
immune system is prone to recognize as
fast replicating cells which is
something that it's not yet so that will
be the idea of retraining it and
speaking about that the future of the
immunotherapy is actually personalized
medicine well that's what people are
trying to get so for example if i have a
tumor they will be able to grab a little
piece of the two more analyze all the
different signals that are in there the
positive than negative potentiate the
positive ones cancel out the negative
ones and create a special cocktail of
drugs that's specific to me and that way
i can get rid of my cancer and that will
be the ideal situation but to do that we
have to study all the multiple receptors
all the different signals and it's a
very long process but it's definitely
been happening all these people it's the
most exciting field right now in
immunology and cancer so it's very very
cool and as I said increasing the
long-term survival of patients is now
the goal of immunotherapy so we're kind
of rethinking how to treat patients in a
long-term way and as I said no more
regressions if you have tumor immunity
there will be no more regressions you
won't have the same cancer again which
is a problem we see with chemotherapy
and everything else so that's kind of
the idea behind cancer immunotherapy
pushes yeah I think guys have any
questions you said that right is that
the next one question that's exactly
what what about colitis and all that
stuff that wasn't right that's exactly
what that shows so it does create an
autoimmune disease and we block this
with things like tnf alpha blockers
which are certain types of treatments
patients that already have an autoimmune
disease and then develop cancer that's a
very rare case it's a very rare
coincidence so I mean that's a very
complicated thing you don't want to have
a patient that already has an overly
active immune system to activate it even
more right so in that case probably
immunotherapy would not be the best
course of action it also again depends
on the type of cancer many types of
cancer respond very well to
immunotherapy for example skin cancer
skin cancer is very good for some reason
that we kind of don't understand yet
it's is that very good response but
other types of cancer don't so for
example if there's someone has an
autoimmune disease has a terminal cancer
that is very responsive likelihood is
you can still reactive a little bit more
without without a [ __ ] name too much so
the entire point of these kind of drugs
is finding a clinical window where the
drug dose is exactly enough to cure
cancer but not reactivate your immune
system too much
yes it can be done it has been done it
is not the reason it hasn't been like so
fast and growing is because cancer draws
all the money in right but yes it has
been done actually I probably that's how
it all started I'm actually not sure but
probably that's how it all started